damit kommen wir zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt da geht es darum wie
innovativ Deutschland ist es gibt
einerseits den sogenannten bundesbericht
Forschung und Innovation 2022 der vom
Bildungsministerium alle zwei Jahre
erstellt wird und die anderen
andererseits gibt es ein Gutachten zu
Forschung Innovation und technologischer
Leistungsfähigkeit Deutschland der von
einer sogenannten Expertenkommission
Forschung und Innovation
veröffentlicht wurde darüber diskutieren
dann jetzt die Abgeordneten und während
der Bericht des Ministeriums Deutschland
als leistungsfähiges Forschungs- und
Innovationssystem
bezeichnen beziehungsweise sagt
Deutschland verfüge über ein solches
System warnt das Gutachten der
Expertenkommission doch eher davor dass
Deutschland und die EU drohen nach bei
digitaler Technologie den an zu
verlieren
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen verehrte
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer das
Leitmotiv unserer neuen Bundesregierung
lautet mehr Fortschritt Wagen und wir
sind angetreten um den technologischen
Fortschritt zu beschleunigen um
Forschung schneller und Anwendung zu
bringen und um die großen
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit mit
Innovation zu begegnen und ich danke der
Expertenkommission Forschung und
Innovation für das Gutachten 2022 indem
sie in bewährterweise Forschung und
innovationspolitischen Vorhaben der
Bundesregierung kommentiert und
Empfehlungen formuliert hat und eine
elementare Zahl vorweg
3,14 Prozent den wirtschaftsstaat und
Hochschulen gaben im Jahr 2020 knapp 106
Milliarden Euro für Forschung und
Entwicklung aus und Staat und Wirtschaft
verfolgen gemeinsam das gleiche Ziel
Deutschland zum innovationsstarken
Standort zu machen und wir dann auch
nicht beim Europa Ziel der drei Prozent
sondern wollen den Anteil an Forschung
und Entwicklung auf 3,5 Prozent des
nationalen Bruttoinlandsprodukts
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben
und der Staat hat seinen Anteil erfüllt
die Ausgaben des Staates und privater
Institutionen ohne erwerbstrecke stiegen
im Jahr 2019 um 3,8 Prozent von 15
Milliarden auf 15,6 Milliarden die
Wirtschaft jedoch verringerte ihre
Ausgaben leider corona-bedingt deutlich
um 6,3 Prozent und daher stimme ich der
Expertenkommission Forschung und
Innovation zu es ist notwendig aufbauend
auf den Erfahrungen der
Hightech-Strategie eine neue umfassende
Forschungs- und Innovationsstrategie zu
entwickeln und auf Basis unseres
Koalitionsvertrages ist das BMBF als
federführendes Ressort bei der Umsetzung
der Zukunftsstrategie Forschung und
Innovation in der Zeit wie geplant
werden die Ressorts zeitnah eingebunden
verbändebeteiligung ist geplant und eine
kabinettsverfassung wird bereits im
Herbst diesen Jahres stattfinden und die
Zukunftsstrategie adressiert in unserem
Koalitionsvertrag verankerte
Schwerpunkte der Forschungs- und in
funktionspolitik kurz gefasst wir wollen
die Rahmenbedingungen und Strukturen für
Transfer und Innovation verbessern wir
wollen bestehendes besser machen und wo
es nicht ausreicht Neues erschaffen
dabei folgen wir den Empfehlungen der
Expertenkommission Forschung und
Innovation die im Koalitionsvertrag
definierten Zukunftsfelder durch
Bündelung und Verschränkung
missionsorientiert zuordnen um
gesellschaftliche Herausforderungen
zielgerichteter lösen zu können die
Missionen stellen dabei ein auf
Transformation zum nachhaltigen Lebens-
und Wirtschaftsweise ausgerichtetes
Instrument da welches die Lösungen und
Erreichung der Ziele nicht vorgibt und
der Forschung und Wissenschaft Freiheit
einräumt und diese Zukunftsstrategie
entwickelnde Transformationsphase werden
die nötigen Veränderungsprozesse
einleiten die wir durch messbare
Indikatoren unterlegen werden
[Applaus]
und die Bundesregierung hat bereits im
Bundeshaushalt 2022 ein klares Statement
abgegeben zur Stärkung
missionsorientierter Forschung und
zentraler gesellschaftlicher Themen wie
Klimaschutz Gesundheit und
Schlüsseltechnologien stellt das BMBF
3,05 Milliarden im Jahr 2022 bereit mit
der dati wird die Grundlage bildet damit
die Umsetzung von Ideen in Innovationen
nicht am Weg scheitert und für den
Aufbau der Dativ sind bereits in diesem
Jahr 15 Millionen veranschlagt und für
die weiteren Jahre insgesamt über 400
Millionen eingeplant das bmbs das BMBF
bleibt damit zuverlässiger Partner der
Forschung den mit dem Pakt für Forschung
und Innovation wird die institutionelle
Förderung von wissenschafts- und
Forschung Organisationen weiterhin
jährlich um 3% gesteigert
damit haben wir die wichtige
Weichenstellung für mehr Fortschritt
Wagen getroffen um vom Wagen ins
gewinnen zu kommen ich danke für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
soweit Mario Brandenburg der
Parlamentarische Staatssekretär bei der
Bundesministerin für Bildung und die
Forschung und auf ihn folgnet den
schönen stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Kollege
Brandenburg erstmal noch mal Glückwunsch
zu ihrer Benennung als parlamentarischer
Staatssekretär es gab zwar die erste
Rede jetzt in dieser Funktion alles Gute
und sie treten das Amt ja in einer nicht
so ganz einfachen Zeit an die Zahlen die
uns jetzt die Tage noch mal erreicht
haben sind schwierig Deutschland die
deutschen Unternehmen verlieren an
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit die
Machtverhältnisse auf den Weltmärkten
ändern sich rasant und das muss uns
natürlich zu denken geben und deshalb
ist es wichtig dass wir dagegen steuern
dass wir gerade in den Bereichen
Forschung Innovation Digitalisierung
nach vorne gehen und deshalb ist es ja
auch erstmal gut dass diese Ampel sich
das den Slogan fortschrittskoalition
gibt und sagt mehr Fortschritt wagen
allerdings auch in ihrem Bericht den sie
heute vorliegen stehen viele gute Punkte
drin auch im Koalitionsvertrag nur mit
der Umsetzung da hab hat es noch ein
bisschen und da warten wir auf konkrete
Ergebnisse nach wie vor jetzt sind die
ersten Entwürfe für den Haushalt 2023 da
das sehen wir dass bei geier-x gespart
wird dass bei Zim gespart wird im
Bereich Forschung Innovation Bildung und
Forschungen in unserem Haushalt ist der
Aufwuchs auch nicht so stark wie in den
letzten Jahren und das könnte ich Ihnen
jetzt natürlich leicht zum Vorwurf
machen allerdings sehe ich auch ein dass
wir uns auch Haushalt herdisch in einer
schwierigen Lage befinden und deshalb
will ich an sie appellieren nutzen sie
doch wenigstens die Hebel die sie haben
die nicht zu viel Geld kosten und da
gibt es einiges
ich nehme den Bereich der Regulierung
Schlüsseltechnologien wie künstliche
Intelligenz wissen wir alle sind der
Schlüssel dafür dass werden allen
Bereichen der deutschen Wirtschaft
wettbewerbsfähiger werden besser werden
und gerade bei der künstlichen
Intelligenz vermisse ich aber jeglicher
Anstrengung dieser Bundesregierung den
richtigen regulatorischen Rahmen zu
schaffen wir verhandeln derzeit auf
europäischer Ebene den sogenannten ai-ac
die erste
weltweite Regulierung für künstliche
Intelligenz und die deutschen
Ministerien das Wirtschafts- und das
Justizministerium können sich
anscheinend nicht wirklich einigen in
vielen Punkten sie werden in Brüssel
nicht deutlich wahrgenommen mit einer
innovationsförderlichen Politik und
viele Akteure kommen auf uns zu und
sagen was dort gerade in Brüssel
verhandelt wird das kann zur echten
Wachstumsbremse im Bereich der
künstlichen Intelligenz werden
und das muss uns besorgen und deshalb
bitte ich Sie dass Sie gerade in diesem
Bereich aktiver werden tätig werden und
für eine innovationsoffene Regulierung
sorgen die
Geschäftsmodelle Möglichkeit
möglich macht und die nicht verbietet
sondern Testfelder ermöglicht die
Spanier haben angekündigt eigene
Testfelder zu gründen auch das ein
deutscher Ansatz hier können Sie tätig
werden und etwas für den
Innovationsstandort Deutschland tun ohne
auch nur einen Cent auszugeben
das gleiche gilt für das Thema Umgang
mit Daten und das hängt natürlich eng
zusammen hier ist es ein bisschen
spannend wie sie das aufgeteilt haben in
der Bundesregierung da muss ich jetzt
wirklich nachgucken weil ich kann mir
das überhaupt gar nicht alles merken
also fährt den Deiter Act international
ist Herr Wissing zuständig nationalhabek
für das dateninstitute Habeck und Frau
Feser fürs datengesetz gibt es noch
keine Zuständigkeit für KI haha back und
Herr Buschmann und ich vermisse jetzt
bei allem Frau stark Watzinger
die ist für die KI zuständig allerdings
zusammen mit Habeck und Heil also das
klingt alles nicht nach einer Studenten
digital und auch nicht nach einer
Studenten datenpolitik das klingt nicht
danach dass das was sie immer sagen
nämlich Datenräume zu schaffen mit Daten
zu arbeiten Innovation durch Daten zu
ermöglichen dass sie das auch wirklich
umsetzen und auch hier mein Appell ist
kostet nicht klären Sie Ihre
Zuständigkeiten und kommen Sie zu einer
Studenten digitalen und datenpolitik das
ist ganz wichtig für den
Innovationsstandort Deutschland
und das dritte Anliegen dass ich habe
ist nutzen Sie die Hebel die da sind wir
haben am Freitag im Plenum einen Antrag
zum ipci im Bereich der Biotechnologie
im Bereich helf Biotechnologie auch eine
weitere Schlüsseltechnologie die sie
auch in ihrem Gutachten erwähnen sie
erwähnen auch das Instrumentarium dieser
gemeinsamen Anstrengungen auf
europäischer Ebene das instrumentalium
der ipci und jetzt wird gerade eins in
Brüssel verhandelt etliche Staaten
machen mit und wo ist Deutschland
wir sehen keine Bemühungen in
Deutschlands bei dieser Initiative
mitzumachen auch hier lassen sie Chancen
und genutzt liegen das ist ein Hebel der
gerade den biotechnologiestandort
Deutschland helfen würde und auch das
nutzen sie nicht stattdessen
verheddern sie sich weiterhin bei der
Gründung einer Agentur für Transfer und
Innovation dabei haben wir schon
Agenturen die Agentur für Sprint und
Innovation die Agentur für
cyber-innovationen es werde viel
sinnvoller hier diese Agenturen zu
entfesseln ihn mehr Möglichkeiten zu
geben mehr Freiräume zu geben vielleicht
auch Satelliten zu gründen in den
Regionen und aus dem was wir haben auch
die Projektträger des bmbfs sind ja
durchaus gute Einrichtungen die zu
entfesseln den mehr Möglichkeiten zu
geben das würde mehr bringen als eine
Nazi zu gründen die gerade von den
Gutachtern die auch das e-fi-gutachten
geschrieben haben kritisiert wird sie
sagen das bringt nur Doppelstrukturen
führt aber nicht zu dem nötigen Ziel da
könnten sie Geld sparen die anderen
Sachen können Sie umsetzen ohne dass es
Geld kostet und wenn sie dann noch ein
bisschen umschichten und wirklich in die
Wachstumsfelder investieren dann können
Sie auch den Slogan Fortschritts
dieser Zeit sieht das alles noch nicht
so gut aus
[Applaus]
und ich erteile das Wort Holger Mann
sb-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Damen und Herren nach Frau
schön zurück zum Thema dieser Aussprache
der vorliegende bundesbericht stellt
alle zwei Jahre die Elemente des
deutschen Forschungs- und
Innovationssystems mit Daten und Fakten
da und gibt offensichtlich Gelegenheit
zur generalaussprache deshalb sei auch
hier mal kurz vorausgeschickt
Deutschland verfügt über ein ausgebautes
und leistungsfähiges Forschungs- und
Entwicklungssystem dass ich auch in den
letzten Jahren bewertet gerade in der
covit 19 Pandemie lieferten die
Wissenschaften schnell
erdrängende antworten auf
gesellschaftliche Fragen und konnten den
kürzester Zeit Nachweisverfahren und
Impfstoffe entwickeln und kommunizierten
verlässlich in die Öffentlichkeit wir
können also zusammen zu recht sagen und
auch stolz auf die Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeiter im System sein das
Innovationssystem hat maßgeblichen
Anteil daran dass unser Land so gut
durch die Pandemie gekommen ist
obwohl nun die beiden beschriebenen
Jahre 2019 und 20 auch von
Einschränkungen in der Forschung
betroffen waren stellt der Bericht ein
durchaus gutes Zeugnis da aus so blieb
das Gesamtsystem unbeschadet sind unter
anderem die Beschäftigten Zahlen
konstant hoch und die Ausgaben nahezu
stabil und an dieser Stelle sei einmal
gesagt dies ist vor allen Dingen der
Kraftanstrengung des Bundes zu verdanken
wir haben zwei Milliarden mehr
investiert und sie wurden auch 2020 der
Staatssekretär das schon gesagt mehr als
drei Prozent konkret 3,14 Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsproduktes dafür ausgegeben
die Wirtschaft dagegen das muss leider
kritisch festgestellt werden gab fünf
Milliarden weniger dafür aus erstmalig
seit einer Dekade sinken deshalb die
Gesamtinvestition letzteres ist ein
klarer Wermutstropfen und muss dringend
umgekehrt werden es braucht also wieder
mehr Initiative aus der Wirtschaft wir
und die Bundesregierung halten
jedenfalls konsequent am Ziel fest die
F&E-Ausgaben bis 2025 nicht auf 3,5
Prozent des BIP zu steigern wir wollen
zu den innovativsten Regionen auf der
Welt gehören
der Ressourceneinsatz selbst sagt
natürlich wenig über den Erfolg des
Systems aus lassen Sie uns deshalb ganz
kurz auf ein paar andere Indikatoren
schauen hier überrascht manches und
durchaus positiv entgegen der
verbreiteten Kritik erreichte
Deutschland 2019 durchschnittlich
doppelt so viele Weltmarkt relevante
Patente vor einer Million Einwohner wie
zum Beispiel die USA Frankreich oder
Großbritannien
gleichzeitig zeigen Fortschritte im
Bereich Transfer und Anwendung auch neue
Aufgaben den wir uns stellen müssen so
haben mehr Unternehmen eine Produkt-
oder Prozessinnovationen eingeführt da
sage ich gut so diese sogenannte
innovatorenquote bleibt aber mit 55
Prozent im Vergleich noch zurück und
sinkt ausgerechnet bei den deutschen
Großunternehmen auch die gründungsrate
bleibt trotz leichten Wachstums
international deutlich zurück weil in
Deutschland Wagniskapital fehlt und da
kommen wir zu dem Punkt den Sie gerade
kritisch angesprochen haben Frau schön
ja die Ampelkoalition arbeitet deshalb
mit dem aus- und Aufbau zweier Agenturen
an dynamischeren Förderstrukturen Sprint
D fördert disruptive Innovation und
schließt eine Lücke im deutschen
Innovationssystem über ja wir gemeinsam
kann ja mal sagen aber über 1.000
wettbewerbseinreichungen in den ersten
zwei Jahren zeigen dass es eben nicht an
Ideen fehlt wir werden hierfür noch mehr
Schwung sorgen und das hat der letzte
Haushalt und wird wohl auch der kommende
Haushalt auch deutlich unterstrichen
auch das sei noch mal gesagt Frau schön
die Gründung der Daten die sie hier
redundant kritisieren soll den Transfer
insbesondere aus den Haws stärken und in
den Regionen mit der Förderung
anwendungsnaher Forschung zum Gelingen
von Transformation beitragen gerade
heute hat die SPD-Fraktion hierzu ein
shareholderdialog durchgeführt weil eben
noch nicht alle Fragen ausdiskutiert
sind wir wollen aber dass dieses Projekt
gelingt
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir stehen vor großen gesellschaftlichen
Herausforderungen aktuell wächst der
Bedarf in der Energie und
mobilitätsforschung die Pandemie und der
Krieg zeigen dass wir gesellschaftliche
Resilienz und technische Souveränität
ausbauen müssen dies wollen wir mit
forschungsmissionen vorantreiben Ziele
klarer adressieren und die Bürger durch
Wissenschaftskommunikation stärker
beteiligen dann wird Forschung und
Innovation der Schlüssel für eine
Zukunftsfähigkeit unsere Gesellschaft
bleiben vielen Dank
Holger Mann war das für die SPD und er
sitzt wie auch der nächste Redner im
Ausschuss für Bildung Forschung und
Technikfolgen Abschätzung Michael
Kaufmann spricht jetzt für die
afd-fraktion
sehr geehrter frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Abgeordnete zu
Beginn eine positive Anmerkung 2020 hat
Deutschland mit Gesamtausgaben für
Forschungen und Entwicklungen Höhe von
3,14 Prozent vom BIP mehr investiert als
die meisten anderen EU-Staaten soweit so
schön doch Geld ausgeben allein löst
noch keine Probleme es kommt viel mehr
darauf an die mittels so einzusetzen
dass die Freiheit und der Wohlstand
Deutschlands auch langfristig gesichert
werden und da
versagt die gegenwärtige Regierung
ebenso kläglich wie ihre Vorgängerin
gender Studien mögen zwar ein
ideologisches Bedürfnis von Grünen und
SPD befriedigen sie lösen jedoch keines
der drängenden Probleme in unserem Land
wie weit die ideologische Beschränkung
der Wissenschaft inzwischen geht zeigte
sich jüngst an der
Humboldt-Universität die sich mit
wissenschaftsfeinden aus dem linken
Milieu gemein machte und einen Vortrag
einer ihrer Wissenschaftlerinnen
verhinderte
dass sie Frau stark Watzinger sie glänzt
heute durch Abwesenheit wie die anderen
Regierungsmitglieder auch also bitte
Herr Staat Brandenburg richten sie doch
das aus dass die Frau stark Watzinger
und auch ihr geschätzter Kollege Kubicki
daran deutliche Kritik geübt haben
begrüßen wir als AFD ausdrücklich aber
denken Sie auch einmal darüber nach ob
sie sich vielleicht die falschen
Verbündeten gesucht haben
der positive Grundton des bundesberichts
ist der Lage nicht angemessen denn
deutschland verliert bei Forschung und
Innovation den Anschluss der globale
Innovation Index für Deutschland nur
noch auf Platz 10 weltweit das
kontokariert den regierungsslogan mehr
Fortschritt Wagen das kontokariert auch
die ambitionierten Ziele die Herr Mann
von der SPD gerade formuliert hat das
ist entschieden zu wenig für die größte
Volkswirtschaft Europas und gerade zu
beschämend wenn man bedenkt dass unser
Land für seine Innovationen und seine
Technologieführerschaft bekannt und
geschätzt war
in einem Bereich jedoch attestiert der
Bericht Deutschland eine führende
Position und zwar in der
Innovationsfähigkeit mit anderen Worten
das Potenzial deutscher Forschung ist
nach wie vor vorhanden doch es gelingt
nicht mehr dieses Potenzial zu heben das
sollte Anlass zu Demut und Selbstkritik
sein man versetzte sich einmal in die
Lage eines jungen motivierten
Wissenschaftlers der sich überall von
ideologischen Barrieren eingeengt sieht
an der friedlichen Nutzung der
Kernenergie darf er nicht forschen an
der Optimierung von Verbrennungsmotoren
erst recht nicht und auch
systemische Kraftstoffe sind ideologisch
nicht erwünscht und diese Liste ließen
sich beliebig fortsetzen niemand von uns
weiß auf welchem Gebiet ein genialer
Kopf die nächste revolutionäre
Entdeckung machen wird derzeit ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch dass dieser
geniale Kopf zwar in Deutschland
ausgebildet wird
sein Wissen und seine Ideen aber lieber
im Ausland nutzt und den marktfähige
Innovationen umsetzt und genau deshalb
braucht Deutschland endlich wieder eine
technologieoffene Forschungsförderung
[Applaus]
auch
auch das McKinsey global Institute
attestiert in Europa gerade erst in fast
allen wichtigen Technologiebereichen den
Anschluss zu verlieren dadurch werden
europaweit bis 2040 zwei bis vier
Billionen Euro jährlich an Wertschöpfung
verloren gehen die Forschungspolitik der
Bundesregierung verspielt somit unseren
zukünftigen Wohlstand das darf nicht so
weitergehen unternehmen Sie etwas bevor
es zu spät ist beseitigen Sie die
ideologisch motivierte stranken aus dem
Köpfen unserer Forscher gestalten sie
Forschungsförderung wieder
technologieoffen und beenden Sie den
brain drain in dem sie einen
Innovationsklima schaffen das junge
Talente motiviert ihre Zukunft ihr gerne
und aus Überzeugung bei uns in
Deutschland zu suchen vielen Dank
Michael Kaufmann ist ja auch noch mal
auf die Debatte um einen Vortrag an der
Humboldt-Universität eingegangen zum
Thema Geschlecht und gender der abgesagt
wurde während der langen nach der
Wissenschaft und auf ihn antwortet Laura
Kraft sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Forschung
ermöglicht Fortschritt es braucht gute
Forschung um Pandemien aufzuhalten um
den Klimawandel zu bremsen und um
Antworten auf die vielfältigen
Herausforderungen von morgen zu finden
und gute Forschung braucht aber auch
gute Rahmenbedingungen die Verwertung
von Ideen hin zu neuen Innovationen und
Unternehmensgründungen bleiben in
Deutschland noch hinter den Erwartungen
zurück so heißt es im bundesbericht
Forschung und Innovation und das liegt
auch daran dass Forschung Wirtschaft und
Gesellschaft in der Vergangenheit zu
wenig zusammengedacht wurden aber erst
wenn wir diese Aspekte zusammendenken
dann wird Innovation möglich
Invest
ition Investitionen in Forschung
Innovationen sind in der Tat eine
Investition in die Zukunft und der
bundesbericht benennt es hier genau
richtig wir befinden uns im Aufbruch in
ein transformations Jahrzehnt aber
wegzukommen von Gas von Kohle von Öl das
ist kein einfacher Weg und wir müssen
jetzt hierfür die Weichen stellen und
für eine nachhaltige klimaschonende
Zukunft Methoden fördern und auch
unterstützen und eine solche
Transformation sie ist notwendig und sie
erfordert aber auch erhebliche
wirtschaftliche und gesellschaftliche
Anstrengung und auch Veränderungen wir
müssen hierfür auch die Forschenden und
die innovator:innen die nötige
Unterstützung bieten das müssen wir
sowohl finanziell machen als auch
legislativ
und dazu gehört auch eine
leistungsstarke digitale Infrastruktur
und wir müssen auch endlich
bürokratische Hürden abbauen und
Deutschlands Rolle in Europa aber auch
weltweit wird dadurch gestaltet wie wir
mit Innovationen in unserer Gesellschaft
umgehen und vor dem Hintergrund des
angriffskriegs gegen die Ukraine müssen
wir auch unsere Forschungskooperationen
noch mal ganz neu in den Blick nehmen
Wissenschaft und Forschung bietet die
Möglichkeit Brücken da aufrecht zu
erhalten und ein Dia im Dialog zu
bleiben wo an anderer Stelle vielleicht
schon längst Brücken abgerissen wurden
und das ist in diesen Zeiten besonders
wichtig gut
[Applaus]
gute Forschung ist auf Kooperation
angewiesen aber wir müssen auch ja
unsere Partnerschaften angesichts der
neuen weltpolitischen Lage noch mal ganz
neu in den Blick nehmen und die Zukunft
daraus aus darauf ausrichten wir müssen
im Zweifel eine größere Souveränität für
uns aufbauen und gleichzeitig aber enger
mit unseren verlässlichen Partnerinnen
und Partnern zusammenhalten und durch
gelungene Forschungs- und
Innovationspolitik stärken wir
Deutschland als Wissenschaftsstandort
und auch im internationalen Wettbewerb
und dafür wollen wir als Ampelkoalition
auch die richtigen Weichen stellen es
ist Zeit dass wir die Erkenntnisse wie
sie uns auch der bundesbericht liefert
nicht nur wahrnehmen sondern auch
endlich im politisches Handeln
überführen die Herausforderung der
Zukunft sie sind groß sie sind Ernst
kommen die Zeiten knapp packen wir es an
ich bedanke mich
[Applaus]
und das ist die nächste Rednerin ist Dr
Petra Sitte Fraktion DIE LINKE
Dankeschön frau Präsidentin meine Damen
und Herren hach Frau Kraft als hätten
wir zusammengeschrieben ich kann hier in
bredebeitrag sozusagen fortsetzen und
vielleicht in dem einen oder anderen
Punkt als
Oppositionsfraktion noch mal auf den
Punkt bringen ja wir beraten einen
Bericht der Bundesregierung ein Auftrag
gegebenen Bericht von der
Bundesregierung und des
Expertengutachten zu Forschung und
Innovation zur technologischen
Leistungsbereitschaft Deutschlands 2020
und das Besondere ist halt für das
Publikum ist das wichtig es werden die
vergangenen Regierungsjahre bewertet
nicht die jetzige Regierung mit den für
sich verschärfenden gesellschaftlichen
großkrisen also genau vor dem
Hintergrund dieses Berichtes als da sind
der Ukraine Krieg die Klimakatastrophe
corona-pandemie eine globale Hungersnot
und wachsende soziale Spaltung stellt
sich also hier die Frage soll so weiter
gemacht werden sie haben genau diese
Frage jetzt selbst auch aufgeworfen und
wir sagen wie sie nö so wollen wir nicht
weitermachen
eine für eine Bewältigung dieser Krisen
brauchen wir eine
innovationswissenschaftspolitik die
Forschung an genau diesen Themen
verlässlich langfristig finanziert sie
muss der Komplexität durch kooperative
Ansätze Rechnungen tragen statt mit
unzähligen wettbewerblichen vergaben in
gesplitteten Förderprogramm oder
Exzellenzinitiativen Ressourcen von
Forschenden ohne Ende zu verschleißen
Zeit Nerven ich kann das gar nicht alles
ausführen letztlich sind dann aber doch
alle Projekte nur befristet finanziert
starke Kritik an dieser Praxis kommt
auch aus der Wissenschaftscommunity
selber meine Damen und Herren ja es
stimmt wir haben Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler die mit hoher
Motivation lernen und forschen und das
zum Teil unter unfassbar schlechten
unsicheren Beschäftigungsbedingungen es
stimmt mit den Hochschulen Universitäten
und außeruniversitären for
Zieleinrichtungen der Deutschen
Forschungsgemeinschaft und der
Förderlandschaft haben wir ein
Riesenpotenzial aber dieses Potenzial
wird seit gut 20 Jahren immer enger
geführt zunächst wurde die
unternehmerische Hochschule etabliert
und das alles bei unzureichender
Grundausstattung von Lehre und Forschung
nunmehr und das ist meine Befürchtung
verschiebt sich die Debatte oder
verschiebt die Debatte um die Agentur
für Transfer und Innovation für die
Hochschulen für angewandte
Wissenschaften eventuell auch für kleine
Universitäten und um die Zukunft der
Bundesagentur für sprunginnovationen
diesen Schwerpunkt immer mehr von der
Lehre und Forschung hin zum Transfer in
Unternehmen wir brauchen uns hier nicht
irgendwie heilig reden natürlich müssen
Ergebnisse wissenschaftliche
Erkenntnisse umgesetzt werden aber
Wissenschaftspolitik ist eben mehr als
Wirtschaftspolitik ich habe es immer
schon zu Herrn Sattelberger gesagt
Wissenschaftseinrichtungen sind
industrieforschungseinrichtungen wie
frei kann man denn sein bei dieser
Ausrichtung wie frei kann denn da noch
gelehrt und geforscht Sie bitte zum
Schluss und jetzt haben sie selber
nochmal sich auf das Schild gehoben
soziale Innovation was muss in der
Gesellschaft passieren was muss in
sozialen Bereichen passieren
Rentenpolitik etc überall dort brauchen
wir Forschungsergebnisse auch aus der
Wissenschaft und deshalb sagen auch wir
steuern Sie um Wissenschaft und
Forschung sind öffentlich finanziert sie
sollen also den Menschen hier diesem
Land lokal national oder eben europäisch
durchaus zugute kommen dass es unsere
Aufgabe ist wirklich der letzte Satz
soweit also der letzte Satz der
Sprecherin für forschungstechnologie und
Innovationspolitik der Linksfraktion
hier im Deutschen Bundestag Petra Sitte
nächster Redner ist Holger Becker für
die Sozialdemokraten
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen Kollegen wir begrüßen es
außerordentlich dass es Berichte gibt
wie den hier vorliegenden bundesbericht
Forschung und Innovation 2022 genauso
wie den Bericht der Expertenkommission
für Forschung und Innovation der seit
2008 aus meiner Sicht immer eine
anspruchsvolle Mischung aus
Orientierungen Hausaufgaben für die
Regierung darstellt
bedenkt man dass im evi-bericht unter
anderem von der Idee eines klimaklubs
und der Forderungen nach verbesserten
Bedingungen für Start-ups in unserem
Land die Rede ist da kann man nach der
Veröffentlichung der das ersten Entwurfs
der start-strategie der Bundesregierung
und auch den Ergebnissen des g7-gipfels
sagen ja wir sind zügig dabei unsere
Hausaufgaben zu erledigen
auf anderen Feldern allerdings wird
deutlich darauf hingewiesen dass
Deutschland im internationalen Vergleich
noch hinterher hängt und das zentrale
Thema hier ist ich glaube das wundert
keinen Digitalisierung ob nun
Digitalisierung unserer Verwaltung oder
innerhalb einzelner Branchen hier haben
wir definitiv aufzuholen und dieses
aufholen ob im Bereich Digitalisierung
aber auch in anderen
innovationsbereichen ist erklärtes Ziel
dieser fortschrittskoalition und ich
kann Professor Kantner und sein Team von
der Friedrich schiller-universitäten
Jena nur dazu auffordern uns auch
weiterhin kritisch auf diesem Weg zu
begleiten
nicht umsonst taucht der Begriff
Forschung 94 mal in unserem
Koalitionsvertrag auf das können wir
sagen ist ein quantitativer eine
qualitative Aussage auch qualitativ
wollen wir durch bessere
Rahmenbedingungen für Hochschule
Wissenschaft und Forschung den
Wissenschaftsstandort kreativer und
wettbewerbsfähiger machen dazu eine
meiner lieblingspassagen
Koalitionsvertrag wir brauchen ein
digitalisierungsschub zum Abbau von
Bürokratie ich glaube das eint uns alle
hier in diesem Haus
und genauso eint uns wahrscheinlich die
Spannung darauf auf die Veröffentlichung
der digitalstrategie der Bundesregierung
das wird spannend ja noch mehr als die
vorliegenden Berichte selbst allerdings
begrüße ich dass wir hier stehen und im
Plenum des Deutschen Bundestages über
Forschungen und Innovation reden
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen erlauben
Sie mir an dieser Stelle wirklich ein
sehr persönliches Wort als
Naturwissenschaftler und jemand der die
letzten 30 Jahre im Bereich Forschung
und Innovation zugebracht hat sowohl in
dem Bereich der Hochschulen als auch in
der freien Wirtschaft möchte an dieser
Stelle einfach mal klar sagen
Klimawandel Ernährung globale Gesundheit
Energie Umwelt aber auch persönliche
Entwicklungsperspektiven
Chancengleichheit und der Erhaltung des
gesellschaftliches gesellschaftlichen
Wohlstandes Wissenschaft und
Innovationen beinhalten die Antwort auf
alle diese drängen Herausforderungen
dieser Zeit das geht auch aus der
heutigen Erklärung der fünf großen
naturwissenschaftlichen
Fachgesellschaften Deutschlands hervor
die eine Stärkung der Forschung in
Deutschland fordern
Wissenschaft ist es die den Weg bereitet
für echten technologischen und
industriellen Fortschritt Innovationen
schaffen die Basis für fortwährende und
nachhaltige wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
und Lösungen unserer alltäglichen
Probleme wir alle sollten uns daher die
Frage stellen haben Wissenschaft und
Innovationen in unserer Gesellschaft und
im politischen Diskurs eigentlich
angesichts dieser hohen Bedeutung den
richtigen Stellenwert nutzen wir das
wissenschaftliche Know-how das uns im
politischen Bereich eigentlich zur
Verfügung steht wirklich aus
leider lautet in meiner Wahrnehmung die
Antwort auf diese Fragen nein die
fortschrittskoalition ist dafür
angetreten dies zu ändern und ich
persönlich sehe meinen Beitrag in diesem
Haus genau darin diesen Themen mehr
Stimme zu verleihen nur wenn es uns
gelingt Wissenschaft und invationen
Politik und Gesellschaft stärker zu
verankern und daraus entsprechende
Handlungen abzuleiten auf allen
gesellschaftlichen Ebenen dann können
wir in Europa und auch darüber hinaus
eine Spitzenposition einnehmen das muss
unser Anspruch sein für eine
freiheitliche demokratische nachhaltige
und gesellschaftlich vorbildhafte
Perspektive für die Menschen in unserem
Land daran wollen wir mit aller Kraft
Arbeiten vielen Dank
[Applaus]
dr Anna Christmann Bündnis 90 die Grünen
ist die nächste Rednerin
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich begrüße
auch sehr diese Debatte heute die
Bedeutung von Forschung und Innovation
ist uns hier glaube ich ein gemeinsames
Anliegen aber es ist auch klar wir
müssen einige Dinge anders machen damit
wir schneller vorankommen als das in den
letzten 16 Jahren der Fall war das eine
ist
Missionen formulieren und da haben wir
die Zukunftsstrategie Mario Brandenburg
hat es vorgestellt wir haben ganz klar
sechs Missionen definiert wo wir
hinwollen und es wird ganz entscheidend
sein dort auch klare Messlatten zu
belegen wo wir hinwollen und wie wir das
erreichen und wir haben das aber auch
schon in einigen Punkten getan es ist
nicht so dass alle Dinge quasi viel Zeit
brauchen werden sondern wenn ich an den
Bereich denke dass Luftfahrt
Forschungsprogramm ich gucke den
Kollegen ja zombeck an das auch in dem
Bericht vorkommt wie ich festgestellt
habe ist heute jetzt schon das
luftfahrtforschungsprogramm Klima Lupo
klim geworden eine Neuerung die wir als
Ampelkoalition eingeführt haben wo man
jetzt bei Anträgen darlegen muss was
denn der dekarbonisierungseffekt eines
Projekts sein wird hier sehen wir
missionsorientierung klare Ziele das hat
einen Effekt sofort auch für die
Ausrichtung fürs Klima
wichtig ist natürlich neben
missionsorientierung auch klar
Hochtechnologie deeptec zu fördern auch
das kann man aber zusammenbringen
klimatechnologien sind oft DiTech
deswegen haben wir uns auch vorgenommen
mit dem ersten Entwurf der
start-up-strategie den geplanten
deep-tech and clyded fand zu gründen wo
wir klar aufzeigen es braucht
investitionsschwerpunkte gerade für
Forschung und Entwicklung für deeptec
und für Klima denn wir brauchen jetzt
die Lösungen gegen die Klimakrise
natürlich ist Grundlagenforschung ein
ganz zentraler Baustein auf dem das
alles aufbaut es geht nicht darum alles
in eine bestimmte Richtung zu lenken
sondern natürlich Investitionen in
quantentechnologien in künstliche
Intelligenz in all die Dinge die uns
Anwendungen ermöglichen sind ganz
zentral insofern begrüße ich auch dass
das BMWF jetzt auch die Kompetenzzentren
für maschinelles Lernen verstetigt hat
und wir haben uns im Koalitionsvertrag
auch vorgenommen gerade die europäische
Zusammenarbeit in solchen
Hochtechnologien wie KI zu stärken dann
am Ende wenn wir global schauen kommt es
darauf an dass wir als Europa ein
starker Technologiestandort sind gerade
in diesen geopolitischen Zeiten geht es
darum technologische Souveränität hier
auch zu sichern
um all das zu erreichen ist glaube ich
auch ein Punkt sehr wichtig wo wir auch
eine Fortschritt wirklich als
fortschrittkoalition gemeinsam erreichen
wollen und das ist diese Dinge
ressortübergreifend und gemeinsam
anzugehen denn wir haben gesehen in der
Vergangenheit häufig wenn Dinge an
Ressortgrenzen stecken bleiben das führt
nicht zu mehr Innovationen sondern zu
Stillstand deswegen wollen wir viele
Dinge gemeinsam angehen wir erarbeiten
gerade die start-up-strategie zusammen
Kollegen luxic zudem wir das
klimaneutrale fliegen gemeinsam
voranbringen wollen insofern laufen wir
da gemeinsam in die richtige Richtung
und zwar mit hohen Tempo und so wird es
weitergehen
kündigt einer Christmann an für Bündnis
90 die Grünen Mitglied im Ausschuss für
Bildung Forschung und Technik Folgen
abschätzen zunke wie auch die nächste
Rednerin Lina Seidel
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren der diesjährige bundesbericht
Forschung und Innovation zeigt sehr
eindrücklich dass wir mitten in einem
transformationsjahr 10 stecken es geht
um die Digitalisierung unseres
alltäglichen Lebens es geht um die
dekarbonisierung unserer Wirtschaft es
geht um nachhaltige Mobilität es geht um
sozialen Zusammenhang Zusammenhalt und
all diese Herausforderungen werden wir
nur meistern wer wir eine umfassende
Forschung und innovationslandschaft
haben die Technologien entwickelt und
sie dann auch umsetzt und zu diesem
Forschungs- und Innovationssystem
gehören natürlich auch die 420
Hochschulen die wir in Deutschland haben
an den Universitäten wird hervorragende
Grundlagenforschung betrieben und in
vielen Regionen sind die Hochschulen für
angewandte Wissenschaften
der Mittelpunkt von regionalen
innovationssystemen wo sie zusammen mit
Unternehmen mit öffentlichen
Einrichtungen Einrichtungen an den
Lösungen dieser gesellschaftlichen
Herausforderung arbeiten und nicht
zuletzt sind die Hochschulen auch
verantwortlich für die Ausbildung und
Qualifizierung all derjenigen die wir
dann nachher brauchen um diese Ideen und
Technologien umzusetzen in diesem
transformationssystem und das sind auch
der Grund warum wir die Hochschulen in
dieser fortschrittskoalition stärken
möchten und ich möchte hier auf drei
Punkte eingehen erstens wir schaffen die
finanziellen Voraussetzungen von
Forschung und Entwicklung an den
Hochschulen wir führen die
Exzellenzinitiative fort die
hervorragende
grundlagenforschungssicherheit wir
stärken die Forschung an den Hochschulen
wir unterstützen mit der dati die
Schaffung von regionalen
transformationsregionen in den
Wissenschaft Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft
gemeinsam Innovation voranbringen
zweitens wir schaffen gute Arbeit an den
Hochschulen weil wir ohne gute Menschen
Innovationen nicht schaffen und dieses
transformationsjahrsehen nicht gestalten
können und dafür brauchen wir klare und
verlässliche Anstellungsbedingungen
klare und verlässliche Karrierewege ohne
ständige Befristung deshalb reformieren
wir die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen
mit dem wissenschaftszeitvertragsgesetz
wir schaffen mehr Planbarkeit und wir
verbessern die Qualitätssicherung für
Promovierende und drittens unterstützen
wir die hoch bei der Nachwuchsförderung
bei der Ausbildung von Studierenden wir
dynamisieren den zukunftsvertragsstudium
und Lehre und setzen damit gleich mit
dem Pakt für Forschungen und Innovation
wir investieren in Digitalisierung wir
investieren in Innovationen in der
Hochschullehre mit der Stiftung für
Innovationen der Hochschullehre Alters
um Studierende an den Hochschulen zu
stärken das tun wir alles gemeinsam
zusammen mit den Ländern weil wir nur
gemeinsam hier in diesem Haus mit den
Wissenschaftsorganisationen mit den
Hochschulen mit der Gesellschaft dieses
Transformation
gestalten können vielen Dank
sagt Lina Seidel letzte Rednerin ist
geht der Connemann die Vorsitzende der
mittelstands- und Wirtschaftsunion der
CDU
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
näht in Germany eine weltbekannte Marke
sie steht für Qualität Langlebigkeit
Ingenieurs aber auch Handwerkskunst es
waren deutsche Tüftler und ausdenker die
das Fundament für den internationalen
Erfolg Deutschlands gelegt haben
übrigens vom Hidden Champion bis zum
Konzern leider kam aber dieser
Mittelstand in den Beiträgen der Ampel
in der heutigen Debatte genau nicht vor
ohnehin schreiende Forschung und
Innovation für die Ampel kein
Schwerpunkt zu sein denn in der groko
wurde über dieses Thema in der Kernzeit
gesprochen bei der Ampel reicht es dazu
nicht schade für das Thema schade aber
auch für die Betriebe die massiv in
Forschung und Entwicklung investieren in
diesem Jahr geben klein und
mittelständische Unternehmen dafür 24
Milliarden Euro aus
42,6 Prozent der Deutschen KMU weisen
Innovationsaktivitäten aus deshalb ist
der deutsche Mittelstand bei
Spitzentechnologien wie Elektrochemie
oder aber Pharma absolute Spitze und
dafür auch mal einen Dank an diese
Betriebe
aber deswegen muss uns das efegutachten
auch alarmieren denn erstmals sind die
Forschungs- und Entwicklungsausgaben für
Neuheiten im Jahr 2022 gesunken und
dieser Abstieg ist für den Standort
Deutschland brandgefährlich gerade vor
dem Hintergrund auch des Systems
Wettbewerbs mit der Volksrepublik China
und der Aufholjagd genau dieser
Volksrepublik nur einige Zahlen
2000 kam 3,6 Prozent der weltweit
gehandelten hightech-exporter aus China
heute
23,8 und genauso sieht es bei
wissenschaftlich technischen
Publikationen aus dort haben die
Chinesen um das
18,2-fache zugelegt und heute melden die
Chinesen
52,8 mal mehr Patente an als zur
Jahrtausendwende darauf müssen wir
reagieren und darauf müssen die Betriebe
reagieren können denn die
Innovationsfähigkeit die Zukunft steht
und fällt eben mit dieser
Innovationsfähigkeit unserer Wirtschaft
aber Fortschritt ist ein Wagnis wenn
dieser nicht solide finanziert ist und
deshalb wurde auf Druck der Union in den
letzten Jahren das 3,5 Prozent Ziel in
der Hightech-Strategie festgeschrieben
bis 2025 denn ohne Zielmarke ist das
Bekenntnis zum 3,5% Ziel nicht mehr als
schaufensterpolitik deshalb ist es gut
dass der Staatssekretär seit eher langer
langer Zeit wieder einmal eine Zielmarke
genannt hat entscheidend wird aber sein
ob diese eingehalten werden wird denn
wir haben in diesen reden viel von wir
wollen aber nicht wir tun und daran
werden Sie gemessen werden müssen auch
für unser Land
mit jedem staatlichen Euro muss ein
Anreiz geschaffen werden diese starke
hebelwürdigungen wurde mit Zim erreicht
es ist das zentrale Instrument für die
Innovationsförderung im Mittelstand
dieses abzukoppeln ist grotesk und die
Ampel macht nichts anderes seit Oktober
2021 sind keine Anträge mehr möglich
obwohl die Ampel versprochen hat das
Instrument bis zum Sommer wieder zum
Laufen zu bringen das ist jetzt acht
Monate her Sommer ist jetzt wann kommt
Tim beantworten sie endlich diese Frage
die gründungs- und Tele Transfer
Infrastruktur muss ausgebaut werden
gerade KMU haben es oft schwer in diese
forschungsnetzwerke hineinzukommen von
der Forschung zu profitieren deshalb
sind die Empfehlungen aus dem Gutachten
gut das gilt übrigens auch für die
B2B-Plattform die entsprechend erwähnt
werden denn am Ende muss Deutschland das
Land der Tüftler und ausdenker bleiben
das geht nicht ohne den Mittelstand er
war und ist Sie bitte zum Schluss der
Innovationsfähigkeit und deshalb hätte
er heute wenigstens seitens der Ampel
eine Erwähnung verdient vielen Dank
und geht der kornemann schließt damit
die Debatte über den
bundesberichtforschung und Innovation
2022 und das Gutachten der
Expertenkommission Forschung und
Innovation
die jetzt aber an die entsprechenden
Ausschüsse überwiesen werden und dort
weiter debattiert und dann hier auch
noch einmal ins Plenum kommen